they'll son not even up there yet but
I'm sure there is a bright glow
emanating from 20th cincy streets in
Washington that you can see from there
well I think so and I'm glued to six of
my Bloomberg's and they're all telling
the same story that it's almost a
hundred percent that the yellow light
changes in December to break green you
know before going to bed last night I
calculated that any jobs number over
150,000 would be sufficient and I think
importantly because the Fed views the
economy and future inflation through a
Taylor rule and a Phillips curve lens
that speaks to low unemployment and a
noon a route that there's somewhere
around five and a quarter percent which
is now right below that at five and so I
think they're ready to go build a
recalibrate what are they waiting for
why not have a special meeting and say
this was extraordinary and get out front
and provide the leadership that the
markets desiring well because that's not
the nature of the current said I think
we would agree with that Tom their their
their gradual and they want to make sure
that the markets are prepared and unlike
Volker who at one point in the late
1970s shocked the market with a two
percent increase before telling anybody
I don't think that's the nature of this
fed so but I think the market obviously
is anticipating you know a rather quick
and increase of 25 basis points as is
evidenced by the horizon right two years
the 91 basis point I want Mike McKee to
get back to the jobs report bill gross
but I believe this is yields higher bond
prices down how do you adjust in an
unconstrained manner this morning well
hopefully you go into it as we did at
janus with a negative duration that's
the nature of unconstrained and the
beauty of it to prepare for a mild bear
market I suppose they're certainly at
that down day in prices like today and
so yeah very early this week negative
durations you know going short the the
30-year Treasury as opposed to long and
obviously making money at the mung